we want summertime
wedding and in the near future you know
we're start about to start a new year
and there will be a summer in that year
it could be a big year for us you know
it's 20 22. so and yeah
will you marry me
oh my gosh look how you guys are holding
hands how in love are we
so in love
you were
that first person to step out of the
limo but you are also that first
impression rose yeah
and that means
[Music]
that you have to be the last person
to accept
this road
so nate
do you
[Music]
i mean from the first rows to the final
rows michelle this guy is sitting here
right now your guy after it all was
there ever a moment when you were like i
don't know if it's him or in the back of
your mind was he the one through and
through always and this is exactly where
you're supposed to be i think this is
exactly where i'm supposed to be but i
always was constantly like checking my
feelings and monitoring my feelings and
now where nate was in those feelings was
pretty high at the top but i did i mean
there were times where like i did press
him to make sure that i you know was
getting an answer that i needed just
because you know he's not wasn't i can't
even say he is now but he wasn't used to
opening up and being vulnerable and that
was something that was very new and so
you know that's something that we
definitely i challenge you
on
quite a bit you know and
hey he delivered nate what about you as
she just said she challenged you quite a
bit throughout this whole process was
there ever a moment where you were like
truly i don't know if i can do this or
were you always in it i was in it you
know like i i tried to progress through
our relationship as naturally as
possible in like an unnatural
environment right um and you know i just
wanted to like always check my emotions
check my feelings have conversations
with myself there's a lot of down time
right so
you know just always making sure that
that like you know i i know exactly what
it is that i want to do and um and
that's exactly what i did at the end and
this
this is my soul nate oh
i like that hey nothing but nate all
right
you've never been in love before right
yep
so how do you how do you know like it's
always interesting to encounter somebody
who says that because i'm like well how
do you know then okay no i am in love
now and michelle did that you know were
you at all deeply or were you like we're
gonna get him there for me there was a
moment of like extreme clarity for me of
like when my heart and my mind were
completely in sync everything connected
and i was just i was just certain it's
like this is who i wanna spend the rest
of my life with i i could i could hardly
imagine life without her when i would be
laying in bed and imagining and like
that's not really ever really happened
for me right so there's a lot of
different pieces throughout the journey
that i just held on to and i was like
this this is it this is i'm certain this
is i'm i'm in tune this is what i want
for me i don't i don't know like
everybody has the time where like they
were in love for the first time and you
know when you know and it's like this
you know what i mean it comes across
different differently for everybody but
like with my brother and my brother and
his wife
she was his first love um my sister and
her husband he was her first love so it
was not this like foreign thing i guess
so we're really continuing a family
tradition absolutely right like he fits
the mold perfectly but it's just
you know like if you're able to navigate
through those feelings whether you are
17 whether you are 27 whether you are
middle age like it you know like you
just have those strong feelings and when
you know you know and you know
hey yeah he's a 27 year old man who's
never been in love before and now he is
so
round of applause for that
happy blessing
and look i think i will say i think a
lot of us look back and maybe we there
were times when we said i love you and
when you look back and sitting in
maturity you're like wait was i really
in love you know so it's a word we may
throw around too easily and nate you did
not what was it like to watch it all
back i knew you guys had the afr last
night but what was it like for you nate
to watch back because like you know when
i interviewed caitlyn for example
caitlyn said michelle genuinely was all
in with her emotions nate how was you
how was it for you to watch her be all
in with those emotions with other people
too very very early on after the
engagement uh michelle you know michelle
and i had a conversation of exactly how
everything ended um so i you know i kind
of was already you know in the know of
everything and where her emotions were
with she gave you the syllabus okay
all right
exactly right so so i i had already
known uh we had our conversations about
it um and and again like i've said this
a few times already today but
realistically like when you're in this
unnatural environment things like that
can happen right so it's not like you
know you got to just remember like hey
this is a weird environment with 30 guys
one woman things like this can happen
you know like in the in the outside
world i guess like something like that
would probably never happen right but in
this world you know it's you know some
people fall in love with multiple people
some people fall in love with only one
individual some people fall in love with
nobody right and you know there's at the
end of the day like i get to wake up
next to michelle the rest of my life so
hey you know we're back into the into
the real world right so yeah you know it
can only it can only bother you so much
before you're like hey you know what it
is what it is that was the environment
we're in let's just keep it pushed i'm
the happiest guy in the world right now
was the finale airing a relief yeah yeah
you're like yes
it's nice to get on with everything get
it out there was there a moment that you
that was tough to watch that you two had
to talk through when it aired one of the
episodes i think just
i mean nate's laughing so something's in
his mind
we're laughing because the whole thing
is just difficult it's not something
most people have to experience and we
kind of talked about how we were really
in love when we left on that day that we
got engaged but you learned so much
about each other and we had just gotten
to know each other even like more
at like during that period of time and
so you know by the time you're getting
to these you know week three week four
sorry um week eight nine ten of the show
when more serious relationships are
happening now you have like
significantly more serious relationship
as well and so there is like it's gonna
be uncomfortable and you know we didn't
pretend that it was just never
uncomfortable we definitely just said
this is a really weird situation let's
talk about your feelings let's talk
about my family feelings and here's how
we're gonna navigate it just because
it's like
to say we're going to go through this
whole experience unfazed is
not really realistic yeah well innate i
saw that you posted something you know i
mean you posted a beautiful post about
you too and you did say regardless of
the edit is there anything you want to
clear up about the edit no at the end of
the day you know like i completely
understand that there's a story to be
told and i understand that these are
people's you know jobs and this is their
livelihoods how they support their
family everything like that so at the
end of the day like what's most
important is that you know michelle and
i know exactly like our story and our
story is just now beginning to really be
told right so it is what it is i'm just
i'm just happy that you know like we we
do have the rest of our lives to just
continue you know being michelle nate in
minnesota um
this is this is huge because look i've
i've done interviews for the shows for
years and a lot of people say it's hard
when you're trying to do that long
distance like that makes that that's
hard so how important was it to make
that decision to move to minnesota like
nate what does that mean for your work
or anything like that and then why was
that so important for you too for me i
get to work remote which is really nice
in the in the industry that i'm in so
working remote it makes everything so
much easier um but then uh but then also
like you know michelle has a lot going
on in in minnesota right family friends
work um you know school as well um
finished finishing her master's and
whatnot and for austin you know i have a
bunch of friends i've been there for two
years i love my friends i love austin
but realistically like it makes the most
sense for me to go to minnesota and you
know something about michelle and i when
we're talking about the perfect
relationship is definitely family
oriented right and where i'm from my
whole family they're all in winnipeg
which is like a seven hour drive from
minneapolis right so right there it's so
close for for us to like really bring
our families together so
like all the all the all the stars we're
pointing to to minneapolis and you know
it's really easy to make that decision
yeah that right there is from us in the
bachelor family
and that is a i'm i'm gonna cry it's a
down payment on your first home together
you guys got a down payment for a house
i mean how did that that's the first for
the franchise how did that feel
they're like we are gonna make these
work you know down payment or not it was
an incredibly generous gift yeah we're
making this work yes yes
we will figure it out with whatever
comes our way i heard that your moms
have gotten close tell me about what
it's been like to see those
relationships develop they're funny
they you know we just we really did like
nate said we want to bring our families
together being able to
kind of lean on each other's families as
this was all unfolding was incredibly
helpful me getting close to nate's
sister him getting close to
my siblings my family um has been really
special and now that we can do it
together and like physically get
together yeah uh just
i don't know it just it really makes
this all sink in even more so it's been
awesome i mean your parents were a huge
part of this season michelle moms are
approving and they are vibing on it all
moms are off wedding planning
their own mother trips without us they
are in their own worlds like they're
you know yeah they're they are best
friends they're out
okay i don't know we might need another
special the real love story that come
out of it
yes exactly
well tell me where you guys are at i
mean you you're gonna
move to minnesota where are you at with
wedding planning and what the next steps
are for youtube all we know is that it's
gonna be or all we're gonna say is that
we want summertime
wedding and in the near future okay yeah
yeah well you know we're start about to
start a new year and there will be a
summer in that year so are we talking
there will be
a big year for us you know 2022. at the
end i wanted
to be standing in front of my soul mate
and he is definitely standing right in
front of me it's awesome to see you two
sitting because sometimes i do these
interviews and the people sitting in the
chairs are like on either side of the
chair and it's not you two are
you two hold on to each other and um
can't keep your hands off each other so
just like tell me where i love you said
michelle that your relationship has
grown even more since filming stopped
tell me about that growth and what
you've learned about each other and
honestly just how in love you are we
just are i did not realize how much we
align and
like
oddly weirdly align are similar like
sometimes i feel like he's like the male
clone of me
um
he's really good at talking about his
emotions like he's really really
vulnerable with like words of
affirmation actually more than me and so
it's been really cool to see like that
piece of him but also
you know we
have this like intellectual side where
we can just talk about different
conversations and he got on
documentaries and then
you know we're we're goofing around two
seconds later it's just
i feel like we get each other on so many
different levels and it's been really
cool to see how similar we are
and then also see like differences that
we love about each other as well nate
nate's like she covered it all she
really did she really did like it's it's
amazing like give us an hour and we'll
we'll cover so much an hour right like
we'll we'll be goofy we'll be serious
we'll be talking about
like literally we sat down on the couch
the other night for like 40 minutes
because we were eating popcorn and we
were just curious like how does like how
does it pop like what's going on that
like corn can be like put in a microwave
and turned into like like a hard a hard
like solid type of object to like a
fluffy fluff fluffy type of delicious
little treat right and we like for 45
minutes just like went on this crazy
search you
[Music]
oh 100 100
didn't think you were gonna get that
how-to on popcorn right
i mean you're weird today it's a tv show
so now we can tell everybody here's how
you eat the popcorn when you're watching
the show michelle all in all
what grade do you give
you and nate getting through all this
together ooh a plus plus
five colors
[Music]